Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul.
Today.
I'm going to focus on the influence of the Arabic language on modern Hebrew.
If you pay too much attention to politics and conflict than you might think that
Hebrew speakers and Arabic speakers completely isolate themselves from each
other. And that there's no way that Hebrew speakers would let their language be
influenced by Arabic. But this is definitely not the case.
There has actually always been extensive contact between Hebrew and Arabic in
the Holy land. And Arabic has left its Mark on Hebrew.
Arabic influence on Hebrew actually goes back much earlier than the modern
Hebrew era. During the height of Islamic civilization in the middle ages,
Jewish scholars translated many Arabic writings into Hebrew,
but there were many new scientific and philosophical concepts that couldn't be
expressed using Hebrews existing vocabulary.
New Hebrew words were created using related roots and word patterns from Arabic
that were also lone translations, creating Hebrew compound words,
expressions and phrases based on how they were constructed in the original
Arabic.
Many of these borrowings and loan translations are no longer used in modern
Hebrew, but some are.
Like [inaudible] meaning date from Arabic,
meaning history or date, the medical term, meaning nerve.
This comes from Arabic.
This pair of words,
we can see a sound change that took place in the development of modern Hebrew.
In Arabic.
The letter [inaudible] represents a pharyngeal sound that is articulated at the
back of the throat eyes. This sound used to be pronounced in Hebrew,
but in modern Hebrew, it has disappeared.
So I end as pronounced as a simple glottal stop or as silent.
Nimesh,
meaning freckle from Arabic Nimesh also meaning
horizon from Arabic here, we can see another.
Frenetic change that took place in modern Hebrew in Arabic.
The letter off represents a voiceless uvular stop sound like
KA, but pronounced at the back of the throat in modern Hebrew,
the equivalent letter COF is pronounced like a simple sound.
[Inaudible] meaning center from Arabic Marquez.
[inaudible] meaning geometry from Arabic and DISA.
This word now takes on the meaning of engineering in both languages,
but shoot, meaning simple or plain.
This is a lone translation of Arabic here. We see another.
Phonetic change in modern Hebrew. The word in Arabic has the letter thaw,
which represents an emphatic T sound call the Hebrew equivalent Tet
used to be pronounced this way,
but is now pronounced as a simple non-empathetic T sound.
The CA meaning minute sneer,
meaning second in reference to time also came from Arabic during this time
period, specifically from the words ducky. Okay. And Sonya, and once again.
And there's a difference here and pronunciation between the letter off and
Hebrew COF hundreds of years later in the 19th century,
Jewish linguists were dedicating themselves to the revival of Hebrew as a spoken
native language Eliezer Benyehudah often referred to as the father of modern
Hebrew looked to modern standard Arabic as a source of roots and vocabulary that
could serve as a model for an expanded modern Hebrew vocabulary.
He suggested to the committee of the Hebrew language,
that in order to supplement the deficiencies of the Hebrew language,
the committee coins words,
according to the rules of grammar and linguistic analogy from Semitic roots,
especially from Arabic roots, rather than simply borrowing Arabic words,
he encouraged the construction of new Hebrew words that resembled Arabic ones.
For example, the Hebrew verb, gosh,
meaning to plow was based on the Arabic word. How to,
I should point out that when I introduce verbs,
they are given in their dictionary form.
The third person masculine singular past tense form.
This is a common way to present submitted verbs because it clearly shows the
continent. Usually three continents that make up the root of the verb here.
We see another difference in the pronunciation of modern Hebrew in Arabic.
The letter ha is pronounced as a guttural H sound ha in Hebrew,
the equivalent letter cat used to be pronounced this way,
but it's now pronounced.
The verb he give meaning to him.
Migrate is based on the Arabic verb. In this case,
the verbs routes are used in different templates,
different morphological verb patterns,
but the three-letter roots are equivalent.
The differences that the Hebrew root has Gameau good while Arabic has jeam
Jew, except in Egypt, in Arabic where it's good like Hebrew.
So Bo uh, kind of.
Cactus known as a prickly pear or Sabra in English.
This comes from Arabic Saba,
but this word and a colloquial form of it [inaudible] are used to refer to
native born Israeli Jews. It's a metaphor for the character of Israeli Jews,
tough and prickly on the outside, but soft and sweet on the inside.
The Arabic word has an emphatic S sound so,
but the letter representing this sound in modern Hebrew is now pronounced like a
T followed by an S.
A few more words.
That Benyehudah successfully coined include police me,
meaning official from Arabic. Oh, that's.
Me. [inaudible] meaning.
Serious from Arabic, uh, deve courteous or polite,
which comes from the Arabic word, DB, meaning civil courteous or cultured.
And it also has the meaning of author,
which has probably its main meaning today.
Do you belong maneuver.
Which comes from Arabic Tammany, an exercise or.
A drill. There were also loan.
Translations, for example, good moral.
[Inaudible].
In Arabic, in Hebrew, the person being addressed response bulky, Oh,
meaning mourning of light. This is a lone translation of the Arabic response,
which also means morning of light.
Many new words were created from existing Hebrew roots using this derivational
suffix, ER, this was rare in biblical Hebrew,
but very common in Arabic and was used to create some new words in medieval
Hebrew. But this became very common in modern Hebrew,
based on the example of Arabic, for example, the word for parasol.
Shim Shia from Arabic Shamsi.
Both come from the root word, meaning son in Hebrew.
Shamans and an Arabic shuns.
The word from municipality in.
Hebrew Yulia from Arabic. [inaudible].
The types of influences that I've mentioned so far were carefully planned and
implemented by elite influencers of the language and entered the formal standard
variety of modern Hebrew.
But most of the Arabic influence entered casual vernacular Hebrew.
The two main sources of this influence were the Arabs of Palestine and the Ms.
Rakeem Eastern Jews. As I mentioned before, Jews living in Arab lands,
spoke Judeo Arabic Jewish dialects of Arabic that were influenced by Hebrew
and written in the Hebrew alphabet.
When most of these Jews moved to Israel in the 1950s and sixties,
they spoke forms of Judeo Arabic as their native languages and learned Hebrew as
a second language.
These Ms Rakeem formed a majority of the Israeli population from much of its
history. This naturally had an impact on modern spoken Israeli Hebrew,
particularly on its more colloquial form.
Some of this influence is mainly heard in Israel's peripheral talents,
which were originally settled by Ms. Rakeem. For example, I'm a Dube,
an Arabic word, literally meaning to be hit, but used with the meaning of,
to be crazy. Another exam.
[Inaudible].
Actually comes from an Amazon verbal route. Good. She did it via Moroccan,
Arabic. This originally referred to crying or wailing at a funeral.
This word is now sometimes used casually to mean to complain.
But I understand that this verb is now archaic back in Morocco.
Other words are not limited to peripheral towns,
but are apart of Hebrew slang throughout Israel. For example, the word Shavani.
This is short for the Arabic phrase [inaudible] which means look at me,
people in Hebrew,
it means a show off for an attention seeker in the original Arabic word,
ni is the first person singular object suffix in Hebrew,
the verb and the object suffix together are all one noun.
And the suffix is normalized and doesn't change.
So you can say he's a chiffony or we are chiffony et cetera.
Another example, I'm a stool, meaning drunk or intoxicated.
This comes from the Arabic word mustard with the same meaning.
There's a buttock, meaning be careful.
This phrase comes straight from Arabic to Bilich in Hebrew.
It's actually used more assertively than just saying, be careful.
Maybe it's more like you'd better watch out.
Other words have become pervasive mainstream in casual spoken Hebrew to the
extent that some people don't realize they're Arabic though.
It's often hard to know whether these came from Judeo Arabic or Palestinian
Arabic, for example, meaning fun. This comes from the Arabic word,
KF, meaning pleasure or enjoyment.
[inaudible] this right here is a very common modern Hebrew expression,
Isla meaning awesome or great. This comes from the Arabic word,
meaning sweetest or most pleasant.
Soboba meaning.
Cool from colloquial Arabic.
So Baba with the literary meaning of romantic longing,
but in Palestinian Arabic,
it also has the colloquial meaning of great or excellent,
which is the source of the Hebrew term.
But I've heard that it stopped being used much colloquially after Hebrew
speakers adopted it as Soboba.
Absolute.
Meaning satisfied from the Arabic word, meaning happy you are well.
For DECA.
Embarrassment or full paw. This comes from the Arabic word,
meaning scandal, shame, or disgrace.
[Inaudible].
Arabic. This expression means as you like it, or as you wish Allah Catholic,
but Hebrew adopted its colloquial. Meaning of great or awesome bus,
meaning bummer or disappointment.
This comes from the Arabic word for frustration or disappointment.
[Inaudible] us.
Commonly hear this word in its plural form. This comes from the Arabic word.
Ottis meaning pimp,
but in Hebrew it's used to refer to how should I say poorly mannered,
low class men in English. It would be something like, well,
but some people don't approve of this word because it's been used to stereotype
men of Ms. Rocky background.
Some of these pervasive mainstream words are such well known Arabic words that
I'm sure Hebrew speakers consciously use them as lone words.
There's the ubiquitous word,
yellow Hebrew speaking Israelis use this frequently in exactly the same way that
Arabic speakers do with the meaning of let's go or come on or hurry up.
Israelis also often use this word casually to say by,
which is another way the words used in Palestinian Arabic.
And at the end of a phone call, you may hear,
or sometimes just yellow in modern Hebrew,
doubled consonants are not really pronounced as doubled. So in the Arabic word,
you can hear a long L sound, but not really in Hebrew.
Yellow. How did all of these.
Phonetic changes take place in modern Hebrew?
Modern Hebrew pronunciation is based on Sephardic pronunciation,
which was more similar to Arabic pronunciation,
but because most of the early Zionists who moved to Palestine in the 19th
century and early 20th century were from Europe and spoke languages like
Yiddish, Russian and German.
They naturally found some of the characteristically submitted continents,
difficult to pronounce. In essence, they learned Hebrew with European accents,
which became the basis of modern Israeli pronunciation.
If most of the early Zionists had been Miserables,
modern Hebrew today might have been pronounced more like Arabic,
well from Arabic. Well,
meaning by God where I swear God and also really to show surprise
in Hebrew it's used in that way to show surprise,
like really no way or wow.
It's also sometimes used when you're listening to someone speak to show that
you're listening the way an English speaker might say, yeah, right. [inaudible]
et cetera. Right. And Walla is also a popular Israeli news site.
Some Arabic speakers might be surprised to know that Hebrew speakers even use
the greeting from Arabic as a casual alternative to
Shalom. Then there's Habibi from Arabic heavy,
meaning my love for my buddy. And then there's much as noon from Arabic.
Meaning crazy.
Notice that the Hebrew letter Gimel can be modified with an apostrophe to
represent the sound jus rather than good.
This is common in loan words from various languages.
Another one that some people might find surprising is the use of Jani from
Arabic in Arabic. It means it means.
And it's used to explain what you mean by adding information or phrasing like
that is in other words or meaning.
There are also Arabic words that are used in Hebrew as a consequence of its
middle Eastern environment.
There's the word [inaudible], which comes from Arabic.
I'm seeing I'm seeing is a heat wave caused by hot winds coming from the desert,
which can cause spring or fall temperatures to rise by 10 degrees or more.
The word hum scene literally means 50 in Arabic.
This is used as the word for hot winds because of the exaggerated idea that they
last for 50 days,
the Arabic word for 50 come seen is the source of the Hebrew word.
But in Arabic,
the plural form Hamas scene is normally used or a related form. Come on.
Any other words include foods like the ever-present falafel
and hummus hummus foods native to the Lavant region and others like
[inaudible] which Ms. Rocky immigrants brought from North Africa.
I guess you could argue that these words are simply the names of foods and
aren't really a true part of the language, but believe me,
you hear the names of these foods. A lot,
the vast majority of modern Hebrew vocabulary is Hebrew,
whether it was taken from earlier forms of Hebrew or coined from existing Hebrew
roots, but Arabic has definitely left its Mark on Hebrew supplying around
27% of the loan words in the language and serving as a major source
of slang for modern Hebrew in any language slang,
usually derives first from the innovative speech of the lower socioeconomic
classes and then spreads to the mainstream.
And this has definitely been the case with Hebrew,
with slang being borrowed from the speech of Ms. Rocky Israelis,
as well as Arabs in Israel and the Palestinian Territories.
The question of the day for speakers of modern Hebrew,
what words of Arabic origin do you commonly use?
Can you think of any more that weren't included in the video and other people,
are you surprised to hear that Arabic,
lone words and slang are so commonly used in modern Hebrew,
leave your answers in the comments down below. If you enjoyed this video,
then be sure to check out Lang focus on the various social media platforms like
YouTube, Facebook, Twitter, and Instagram. And as always,
I want to say a special thanks to all of my Patrion supporters,
especially my top tier Patrion supporters,
whose names you see right here on the screen,
many special thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.
Yay.